men are famously somewhat
one-dimensional in the Sandler you know
women men are you know are very looks
driven and that's and that's you know
it's hard to really get around that you
know it's hard to deny that men are very
very driven by externals and how how
women look
um however I do think there's a lot more
to it than that there really really is I
think the key the key thing for me
really is being pleased really and being
being nice to be around guys put up with
a lot of crap from women who are sort of
disrespectful or they're not they're
just not cool to be around you know and
I think the more cool you are to be
around the better really and that's
going to make the guy want to hang
around